la presse plus à me la met sur une étude
réalisée conjointement avec des français
des allemands dans lequel on apprend que
30% des revenus de tous les jeux et le
trick confondues viennent des poches de
3 % des joueurs et des joueurs qui sont
considérés comme les joueurs
problématiques sylvia kairouz étude des
auteurs de cette étude
titulaire de la chaire de recherche sur
l'étude du jeu l'université concordia
vous pouvez nous en parler abondamment
madame 15 4 dollars sur cinq inséré dans
ces machines là provient de joueurs qui
quoi qui ont des problèmes
est ce que est ce que ça vous surprend
le résultat si gras enfin celle où ça
nous donne de données pour le québec
on savait on avait des données qu'ils
provenaient d'autres pays qui n'ont pas
nécessairement chiffré de cette façon si
mais qui nous révèle que ses joueurs la
dépense beaucoup et on a été capable de
dire de questionner avec un grand
échantillon au québec en allemagne et en
france des joueurs on est capable
d'établir leur niveau de problème avec
le jeu et le questionner sur leurs
dépenses et ça nous a révélé ces données
là de dire sur l'ensemble de ce qu'il
nous rapporte dépenser ce soir là en
particulier sont responsables de par
exemple pour les machines à sous de 76 %
des revenus qui rentre dans les coffres
des opérateurs que vous hissez jouarre
la problématique de de ces machines à
sous de ces jeux vidéo excusez moi j'ai
pas compris la question vous disent les
joueurs que vous existez pourquoi ils
sont ils sont accros quoi c'est la
proximité c'est l'accès facile
c'est un ensemble de paramètres sorte
que ces problématiques nous c'est une as
et une enquête populationnelle donc
malheureusement on a des chiffres on est
comme en rien sur ballons on envoie une
sonde puis on est capable de dire
écoutez il ya quelque chose qui se passe
il faut qu'on questionne les joueurs
mais d'autres études qui ont parlé avec
les joueurs certainement qu'il ya des
facteurs déjà démontré de proximité de
concentration des machines mais je vous
dirais actuellement les plus gros
questionnement qu'on a c'est sur la
nature même de ces machines là ces
machines là sont programmés ou dans
certains cas dans certaines
caractéristiques pour créer la zone la
zone qu'on appelle dans notre jargon
scientifique c'est d'amener les gens à
rentrer dans un espace
de vide déconnecté de l'environnement et
on perd le contrôle
pour certaines personnes et il faut il
faut quand même garder les choses en
perspective on a une grande majorité
quand je vous dis que c'est une petite
majorité qui dépensent beaucoup il ya la
grande majorité qui dépense sans
problème mais dans une perspective de
d'équité sociale de justice sociale ce
qui occupation pour les personnes qui
souffrent beaucoup de ces problèmes de
jeu c'est important qu'on se questionne
sur les moyens qu'on peut mettre en
place pour prévenir des problèmes on
essaie de ramener ces gens là vers les
habitudes de jeu alors vous êtes que
c'est pas grave mais ces machines là
sont programmés pour amener le joint
donc dans cette zone n'est pas juste à
la machine est ce que ça faisait que
loto-québec le sait très bien qu'on sait
très bien que 80 % des recettes de ces
machines viennent de 3 % des joueurs on
est ce qu'on a commenté ce qu'on vous en
parle de ça oui je dire souvent de dire
loto québec est un acteur important
c'est le québec qui gère le contact avec
les ou des joueurs sur le plancher et on
a souvent des discussions on sur des
résultats comme ça je pense que on est
date en danse internationale avec des
collègues on y est quand même réseauter
dans en australie en europe en amérique
du nord au canada on pense la
responsabilité comme étant une
responsabilité sociétale je pense qu'il
ya une réflexion et la réflexion est
amorcée par le système est amorcée
ailleurs sur cas quelles seraient les
meilleures façons de de presse de
d'offrir le jeu de façon plus
sécuritaire parce que sentant que ça
disparaisse rapport suite à une activité
ludique elle est important par contre
c'est des questions complexes de savoir
comment on peut sécuriser un
environnement de jeu qui qui est plus et
que les thèmes plus sécuritaire c'est
bien dit voilà merci beaucoup madame
queiroz de ses explications ce matin à
la prochaine merci au revoir